[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts lovable divination
professor
cybil trelawny however we're not just
going to be discussing
one or two aspects of her character
we're going to be discussing it all
from her life as a young witch to the
time she spent teaching
and beyond there's a lot of ground to
cover here so
let's get into it first things first
what did civil trolloni
look like what were her physical
characteristics
harry's first impression of trolloni was
as follows
harry's immediate impression was of a
large glittering insect
professor trollony moved into the
firelight and they saw that she was very
thin
her large glasses magnified her eyes to
several times their natural size
and she was draped in gauzy spangled
shawl
innumerable chains and beads hung around
her spindly neck
and her arms and hands were encrusted
with bangles and rings
simple trelloni was a thin woman often
draped in robes and adorned with
glittering beads and accessories
she wore thick glasses that magnified
her eyes
and she spoke in a sort of soft passive
voice that could quickly change if she
became upset
she was a very unusual and eccentric
woman that conducted herself in an
almost
theatrical way though trelloni worked at
hogwarts she was very much aware of what
people thought of her
and her field which meant that she would
spend a lot of time by herself
unfortunately as the descendant of a
great seer cassandra challani
she was subject to a considerable amount
of scrutiny from others
for most of her life starting in
childhood sybil patricia trolloni was
born on the 9th of march
sometime before the year 1963 to a
muggle mother and wizard father
she was a half-blood witch and as i
mentioned the descendant of the famous
seer
named cassandra trolloni who lived three
generations prior
after cassandra no one possessed the
famous second sight
or ability to see visions that is until
trelawny
at the age of 11 she began attending
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
presumably sometime around the year
1974.
before heading off to hogwarts however
sybil got her wand at ollivanders
nine and a half inches long very
flexible and made of hazel and unicorn
hair
when she arrived at the school she was
sorted into ravenclaw house
from an academic standpoint trelloni was
quite a good student
taking divination as an elective subject
and achieving a high grade
on both her owl and newt trelawny was
also purportedly a member of horus
slughorn's slug club
a club for slughorn's most well-liked
accomplished and
sometimes famous students provided that
trelawney was the descendant of the
famous seer
this is certainly within the realm of
possibility eventually
trelawny graduated from hogwarts and it
was at this point in time
that she developed a connection with her
first romantic interest
a man that we don't know anything about
other than his last name
higglebottom in a sort of tragic but
funny sense
the marriage failed after trelawny
refused to take on
his surname we don't have much other
information on this relationship
at all a new graduate with a marriage
that had recently fallen to pieces
trelawney went out into the wizarding
world with hopes of finding a job
her relation to the famous seer
cassandra trulani
certainly helped to get her in the door
for interviews but she was often
ridiculed for her
gifts as divination was not particularly
welcomed
by the wizarding world as a whole this
brings us to her application to hogwarts
it was the year 1979 and trolloni had
met dumbledore at the hogshead in
like many other prospective employers
dumbledore gave trolloni a chance to
apply
because of her relationship to famous
seer cassandra trolloni
however even dumbledore had his qualms
with a field of divination
despite recognizing it as a legitimate
field of magic
while interviewing for her position at
hogwarts dumbledore was actually quite
unimpressed
on a cold wet night 16 years ago in a
room above the bar at the hog set in
i had gone there to see an applicant for
the post of divination teacher
though it was against my inclination to
allow the subject of divination
to continue at all the applicant however
was the great great granddaughter of a
very famous
very gifted seer and i thought it common
politeness to
meet her i was disappointed it seemed to
me that she had not a trace of the gift
herself
i told her courteously i hope that i did
not think she would be suitable for the
post
i turned to leave but of course just as
he turned to leave
ciboltrolony entered into a deep trance
foretelling the fabled
prophecy the same prophecy that would
flip the wizarding world
upside down this was the prophecy that
spoke of the potter's altercation
with voldemort himself the one with the
power to vanquish the dark lord
approaches
born to those who have thriced to find
him born as the seventh month
dies and the dark lord will mark him as
his equal
but he will have power the dark lord
knows not and either must die at the
hand of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord will be born
as the seventh month dies it's later
revealed that sephirous snape
then a fully fledged death eater was
eavesdropping at the door
this led to dumbledore hiring her in
order to protect her from lord voldemort
however trelawny didn't properly join
the faculty until 1981.
when she began teaching at the school
she occupied a classroom
on the seventh floor of the north tower
it was here that she taught what she
knew best
divination divination is an elective
course taught at hogwarts from third
year onwards
in essence it's essentially the art of
predicting the future
there are various ways to achieve this
and methods include but are not limited
to
tea leaves fire omens crystal balls
palmistry
cartomancy astrology and dream
interpretations
however despite joining the ranks of
hogwarts professors
her abilities were not welcomed by some
members of staff
people like mcgonagall who truly
believed that she was a fraud
fully aware that some of her peers had a
very poor impression of her
trelawney very rarely left her tower and
attended
very few hogwarts feasts this was the
case from 1981
when she started properly all the way up
to 1991
1992 when harry first starts at the
school
in 1992 we don't hear of trolloni much
but we do know that at one point harry
attempts to open her classroom door
which is locked he then realizes that
there's a notice on the door
which says the following do not disturb
crystal gazing
in the 1993-1994 school year
harry meets trolloni properly for the
first time when he joins her class
however harry only joined the class in
the first place because
ron decided to so you may have chosen to
study divination
the most difficult of all magical arts i
must warn you at the outset
that if you do not have the sight there
is very little i would be able to teach
you
books can take you only so far in this
field
in this first lesson trelawny made a few
predictions
that neville would break at least one
teacup that lavender brown was dreading
october 16th
and that one of her students would leave
her class forever
later that same year neville broke two
teacups lavender's rabbit was killed
and hermione stormed out of her class in
this
same school year trelawny ended up
making quite a few other predictions
that would also turn out to be true
the next was during christmas when she
refused to dine at a table in the great
hall
explaining that if she joined then they
would become an unlucky party of 13
people
in this situation the first person to
rise from the table is destined for
death
while we didn't find out until much
later on dumbledore
was actually the first to rise and
incidentally was the first to die
as trelloni predicted next in this same
year trelawny entered into a trance and
predicted
that voldemort's servant would be freed
returning to him
that very night this of course also ends
up being true
with scabbers being revealed as peter
pettigrew in the 94 to 95 school year
trolloni became
increasingly concerned with harry
potter's well-being she made predictions
of his death
and made the assumption that harry had
lost his parents because he was born
during winter harry who was born in july
thought this was nonsense but in reality
trelloni was actually right once again
as what she was picking up on was the
soul fragment from lord voldemort
inside of harry the next school year the
95 to 96 school year
was a particularly stressful year for
trelawney this was because ministry
employee
later hogwarts high inquisitor and later
headmistress
dolores umbridge had begun her
tyrannical reign at hogwarts
umbridge was particularly cynical in her
view of divination
and continually asked trolloni to
justify her teaching techniques
proving the existence of her inner eye
upon command
umbridge continued to stalk trolloni
pestering her to prove her abilities
and eventually put her on probation
eventually umbridge fired trolloni
altogether
however before she left the hogwarts
grounds dumbledore came to her rescue
and told her that she could remain at
the school if she wanted to
it was a home after all after being
dismissed by umbridge trelloni was
replaced with the centaur forense
who taught divination in classroom 11.
eventually
however trelloni was brought back onto
faculty when umbridge was suspended
with umbridge gone she was free to teach
again but from this point onward she
would have to share classes with friends
who was kept on as a staff member fast
forward to the 96-97 school year
and trelawney was very much displeased
with the fact that she would have to
work with friends
who she didn't have a high opinion of
unable to find a compromise
it was eventually decided that the
trelawney would be solely responsible
for the fifth and sixth years she felt
humiliated that she had to work with a
horse her words not mine and developed a
bit of a problem with drinking sherry
she even got drunk at horus loghorn's
christmas party
eventually trelawney hit a boiling point
and demanded that dumbledore fire for
ends
however demands were not met the 97-98
school year was an unusual one
voldemort snape and the death eaters had
taken over hogwarts
and some of the teachers were even
replaced however trelawney was kept on
and given that she was a half blood it's
likely that she just got lucky
and flew under the radar eventually when
things really kicked off
in the battle of hogwarts ensued simple
trolloni fought valiantly alongside her
allies
in order to assist with the efforts she
dropped crystal balls on people's heads
notably knocking out fenrir greyback
while attacking
lavender brown after knocking out
greyback she continued to fire crystal
balls
at the heads of death eaters utilizing a
tennis-like serve
that is until the battle had been won
after the war had ended and peace had
been brought back to the wizarding world
trelawney continued to teach at hogwarts
well into the 2010s
much to her delight it's likely that
after the war
she was the sole divination professor
once again
this is because friends was welcomed
back to his herd of centaurs
the absolute last thing we hear about
trelawney is that she wrote a book
entitled my eyes and how to see past
them which explored
trelloni's exploits within the realm of
divination
and that's in effect the entire life of
civil trollony
at least as far as we know the only
thing that i left out of this video
are some of her predictions but i'm
going to make a separate video in the
future
outlining them all if you want that
video comment down below
if you enjoy the content please remember
to like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time would anyone like me to help them
interpret the shadowy portents within
their orb
you